and you've got brian styles from cnn
feigning
shock that trump banned critical race
theory oh i love it and you can tell the
dude has no idea what critical race
theory is i know what it is
can you enlighten us what is critical
race theory yeah can you give us a
definition
critical race theory is basically our
concept of intersectionality
and they make it as confusing as humanly
possible because the whole point is to
criticize what you're talking about and
this can be any kind of theory so any
critical like critical literature theory
is where you go into literature not to
read it and learn about the culture that
came before you
but to criticize it and find problems
with it it's an issue so you're looking
for problems exactly
it seems like a great way to live right
there's no real simple way to define
critical race theory and it's
intentional
so i can pull wikipedia right here and
it's just like overly verbose
yes this is post-modernism it's hard to
they literally say
it is uh they mention it's post-modern
philosophy developed out of post-modern
philosophy
so one of the things they do is uh oh
you know what have you ever seen the
movie coneheads
no i heard you guys talking about it
yesterday you don't but you know what it
is right dan
aykroyd yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and so
i don't know if you've ever seen that
comic
where the aliens it's like the little
blue purple aliens
and they're like looking at a cat eating
food and they were like
the small mammal we have captured is
consuming you know hydrocarbons we are
very pleased by this
yeah and people love these comics and i
see these and i'm like they're just
that's just coneheads conan's is is an
old saturday night live sketch
they made a movie you know like lauren
michaels snl and it's about these aliens
who they have cone heads
and the way they talk is like instead of
calling something a cookie
they would call it a chocolate infused
hydrocarbon mass
i see you are eating a chocolate infused
hydrocarbon mass i will consume this too
and that was the joke like overly
verbose explanations
that's literally what critical race
theorist people do
oh wow easier to fill 50 minutes of a
class when you're
taking three times longer you know
what's funny it's like college
they'd be like i want you to write you
know a thousand words writing an essay
right right right obnoxious i want you
to write a thousand words on you know
this globe and they would be like well
i'll just use a hundred adjectives to
describe what it is instead of saying
it's a solar-powered moving globe we'll
say it is a electromagnetically induced
rotate
rotation device yeah and just a solar
orientation encapsulated water sphere
einstein would effigy
make a big deal about explaining things
as simply as possible if you can't
explain something simple then
you can't you're not able to get it done
something i can't explain to a
five-year-old
i'll read you a couple things they say
firstly critical race theory proposes
that white supremacy and racial power
are maintained over time
and in particular that the law may play
a role in this process secondly
critical race theory work has
investigated the possibility of
transforming the relationship between
law and racial power
as well as pursuing a project of
achieving racial emancipation and
anti-subordination
more broadly but here's my favorite part
white white is property
what does that mean read it white is
property
whiteness is property yeah from the crt
perspective what
the white skin that some americans
possess is akin to owning a piece of
property
what in in that it grants privileges to
the owner that a renter
in this case a person of color would not
be afforded so we
we i say but someone with white skin
which technically it's not actually
white it's a vip ticket yeah you own it
but with someone if it's a person of
color they're just renting their body
i mean this is the metaphor you can rent
skin this is nonsense this is amazing
what the heck no no no they're basically
saying is that white people
have a piece of property like a vip pass
i mean i'm in debt
to the to the the con the country i'm
still in debt to the bank the federal
reserve bank
no no you're you're white but you're but
you're a white man oh i
so i don't have debt yeah it's right to
know right you're a white male it's very
liberating just call up and let them
know
just say hey bank just wanna let you
know i'm white look oh i'm so sorry
about that we'll wipe your deck clean
oh okay oh man think about that like
this this is the thank you
so let's let's do this let's talk about
the natural conclusions
right ladies and gentlemen this is
what's actually happening
in did you see this
oh i have university campus hosts
white's only cafe
in the name of equality let's uh let's
give a round of applause for
the writers of the the 2020 season i got
to admit
you know adam schiff came out with this
tweet saying that was russian
interference
you got you guys saw this right now yeah
so he's like we got a whistleblower
report that there was russian
interference and trump was downplaying
it
and i tweeted like oh come on the
writers are getting so lazy this is just
a reboot of russiagate
one oh i thought you were talking about
russia gateway no he just tweeted it
today
so any anyway i digress i guess the
point is you know the season
it's it's it's it's like we're getting
reruns what is it the gender reveal
party starts a fire
this is the second instance of a gender
reveal explosive device sparking a fire
in california that burned hundreds of
acres yeah
first one was in a while ago but this is
the second time it's happened not this
year
but this is our second occurrence yes
yeah i know so
somebody did a gender reveal started a
big fire somebody did it again
yeah they say history repeats itself
yeah but not in like
this short a time frame well maybe time
speeding up i think so
well maybe but uh i'll tell you what
everybody
here we have the next step in uh
so all of that stuff is filler you know
they're like giving us these filler
episodes of 2020 and we're like we did
the gender reveal
wildfires can we can we get to the story
yes
i don't like it the non-people of color
cafe is a space for students that
do not identify as persons of color to
gather and to discuss their experience
as students on campus
and as non-poc in the world hosted by
the center for social justice and
inclusion
oh how inclusive no i love it if you're
of african-american assembly you don't
identify yes someone of color you could
go there
no you no you found the loophole but but
it's all about how the way you identify
accordingly i mean i guess but i'd
imagine that the white's only
cafe would be like you're clearly not
something so what are they going to do
throw you out
dude my favorite my favorite thing in
this like
you know what man there's the meme of
clown world is
yeah that like the the the the current
history is so absurd it certainly must
have been written by clowns
okay you know it's it's like the writers
of the simpsons and they're like oh i
got a really great idea for an episode
it's gonna be hilarious
they do a whites only cafe and it's
hosted by the social justice and
inclusion center
that's perfect comedy it's it's it's
it's it's irony
it's literally a fire truck driving
around spraying flamethrowers and
burning buildings
i don't think they realize that this is
racist the people that created it
i think there are people who know it's
racist and are very happy about it
oh really yeah i think it's insidious
yes
like it could be that this stuff's
getting funded by someone who wants to
create division
like from the top of the top of the top
i don't think he needs to be so chinese
government whoever i mean it's total
conspiracy theory i
i myself have not read white fragility
and i
i probably should but i'm just right
that's
yeah exactly yeah book on tape yeah
but i'm pretty sure doesn't she say that
she's uncomfortable around minorities
she did yeah
wasn't she the one who said that when
she walked into a room that was majority
minority that she would clutch her purse
more tightly is that what she said
that is something that a racist does i
should look up the quote i just got to
read them so
i'm sorry i think you have avowed
racists like robin d'angelo and some of
these other people
they know exactly what they're doing and
they like it
they want white only space listen this
white fragility lady white fragility is
a nationwide bestseller right now
this is why i'm like we need trump
trump's got a really he
he can't do everything because this is
in our culture but he can do a lot
for now and i'm worried if biden wins
biden's negotiating with these people
and entertaining these ideas
robyn d'angelo said when she goes into a
room she gets
a full of you know marginalized people
i'll use that language
she gets uncomfortable wouldn't she feel
more comfortable in a room for only
white people then
is that the logic no she's straight up
saying she is not comfortable around
people who aren't white
and then all of a sudden now these
universities which probably read these
books because it was a bestseller
are are creating spaces where she'll
feel more comfortable oh
man so yeah appealing to their neuroses
apparently which could be very
detrimental
um i mean okay we're comfortable with
what we know
i get that so if you're unfamiliar with
someone because of the color of their
skin if you're surrounded by all
black people your whole life and then
you go and there's white people around
maybe that will be just new so there's a
discomfort because it's new
or because it's it's cultural
differences yeah of course they're
eating soup and you've only eaten meat
your whole life so it's like i'm i'm
nervous about that
i i went to an event in norway and they
were serving whale
did you eat it i had a tiny piece what
was it like it was awful it's
mammal and and you know it is it is and
so when i went there i was actually kind
of shocked to see it but it's normal
there
and they had a big plate of it and i was
like whoa just like no way dude i'm not
going anywhere near that
and they were like it's totally normal
and it was like pickled or something and
they're like putting it on bread and
it's like mustard or mayonnaise or
something on it and i was just adamant
i'm not gonna eat it
and then they convinced me to at least
taste it and it was awful
and i was unhappy about it and i'm like
it's an american cultural thing to say
f no to eating whale that we won't do
that so when i was i was uncomfortable
it was kind of weird dude i mean the
whales are the great sages of the
of the earth man one of them but i mean
i understand
like wailing in the past but it but it
is a major cultural difference
so anyway the reason i bring that up is
if you if you grew up
in this this really is a a great
perspective into what these people are
doing you hear these stories right there
was one woman she was like
all on twitter they're talking about
privilege they're like when i was you
know 20
i got drunk and crashed my car and the
cop gave me a slap on the wrist
and i'm like yes and you lived in you
know the berkshires
like you lived in long island in the
hamptons and you had a very wealthy
family
and the cops were someone stuffed a lot
of cash into the you know the right
person's pocket
and you're not going to get in trouble
because you're a rich person not because
you're white because you were rich
bail is a the whole system ever since
they would ransom prisoners
from like ancient warfare was all about
taking a duke prisoner and then
ransoming off
immediately if he could afford it
otherwise they sit in prison so it fails
the same way you can buy your way out of
jail
well temporarily yeah temporarily it's a
group for like could be a year and a
half until your case you know
right yup seriously so they they've
tried doing
they've had these knee-jerk reactions in
new york with like cashless bail which
is
resulted in criminals laughing and
walking on committing more crimes what
is it exactly
there was something like cert like
non-violent crimes would be
n no cash bail because if they they
would they argued it wasn't fair that
you would put a monetary value on
whether someone has a right to continue
their life while they're
you know not proven guilty yet and you
know i agree with the sentiment
i just think they in practice they
screwed everything up they did it
horrible
horribly wrong and i think there should
have been a trial period on specific
like one or two specific instances or it
should have just been straight-up
case-by-case basis
but there really there's a good point we
made about you know uh
bail systems and how it
disproportionately affects poor people
yeah you go to you go to jail
and they say you got to spend 600 bucks
to get out and you don't have it
you lose your job you lose your
apartment lose your job that's crazy
yeah so it is so there are challenges
there but then what do we do
right so i've often said i would prefer
to err on the side of freedom
in which case it is better that 10
guilty persons escaped than one innocent
person suffer right
the only problem is that in new york
where they did this they also take away
your right to self defense
so if you're going to release criminals
who are going to go around committing
crimes and you're also telling people
that defense is restricted as well
you're creating a class of you're you're
you're creating a likelihood
of crimes to be committed and an
inability of individuals to protect
their homes their friends and their
families
so it's kind of like i i think
you know hardcore authoritarianism is
the wrong direction but anyway the
the the general point i'm trying to make
about all this is just uh
they conflate race with cash it's
totally
a class thing so what i get what you
mean with with letting a prisoner out
if they can't afford it what's the
incentive of not just going right back
if they're just going to let you ride
out again
we're going back to where we might not
jail they let you out because you don't
need to pay bail because you can't
afford it so they do some social thing
where they just let you out anyway
that's what they've been doing yeah
and especially with covid they released
all these people and they all went
committed crimes and a lot of
rising gruesome yeah man jeez
it's almost like class warfare makes
sense in a way but that it doesn't
no no no it doesn't make sense but but
no one should not have the
ability to to have money or or status or
whatever it is
power i think there is a serious
question around
a poor person being told they got to pay
cash bail
so it's it's tough it really is man
these are these are hard ethical
questions to figure out
the safety of the community versus the
the safe the the freedom of the
individual and the rights of the
individual because we're wild animals
humans are
well apes that have i think
i think the issue is scale so if you
think back to like
i don't know 1700s or even before then
you had a much much
less dense population and so much less
you know very few people were in the
circumstances
now the problem is we're going to have
what several hundred
per week or per day who might be
innocent
the scale of uh you know rights being
trampled over that's getting crazy but
also think about
if there was some dude who's accused of
a crime and he went to
he got arrested and they said you got to
pay bail i'll tell you what
we'll do cashless bail just promised to
come back which they probably wouldn't
have done way back then
but what's what everybody's armed it's
you know farms out in the middle of
nowhere they're all assuming they've got
to protect themselves anyway
now we've got people in big cities
stacked on top of each other everything
smells like sour milk and they're
fighting all the time
and when i say fighting all the time i
don't mean that's like getting worse
actually violent crime is going down
but crime and crime in general still
exists and if you have more people
you will have more crime yeah then
you're gonna have more people getting
arrested and sometimes innocent people
get arrested
so the challenge now is is it better
that 10
innocent people suffer than one guilty
person escape
no that's the authoritarian approach no
yeah it is better that 10 guilty persons
escape than one innocent person suffer
but then you're anyway we're going off a
tangent about this more of a
more of an ethical discussion the point
i was basically bringing up about
everything they're doing is that
when they talk about how they got away
with committing crimes
because of their because they are
racists they assume
race is the driving factor for human
motivation so so here's the important
way to
to frame it people's perception um about
what is happening in the world is based
on how they view them like how they
themselves
work in in the world right so if
somebody
in a in a white progressive upper class
neighborhood
gets into a car accident while they're
drunk and the cop comes up and says
uh-oh
we're going to let you off with a
warning you know this is the mayor's
daughter or whatever or like this is the
daughter of a
high-powered lawyer we're not going to
get into it we're going to let you go
because they are racists themselves and
because they
judge people based on race they assume
they're being judged based on their race
as well get it yeah
so what's happening here is that these
people are actually closeted racists
and because yeah work with me they
they have underlying racism and because
they were
privileged and they had this class
advantage they're like fish and water
they don't even see it
so that when it comes out that they
actually had a leg up they're like well
obviously
this is because of my race exactly that
must be what else could it be do you
remember that guy
to a hammer everything looks like a nail
oh that's brutal
that's true give a man a gun and what
the heck
oh what does that say give a man a fish
that kid who got arrested for drunk
driving i think he might have killed
someone even and then they let him go
for affluence he got off
affluenza he was too rich he didn't know
what was good for him
talk about messed up man come back yeah
class bro class is a thing and under
class this is what i was talking about
the russian revolution man if you ignore
the underclass for too long which is why
i like donald trump at least speaking
out against it and i'm a little afraid
against i don't want to get too
emotional about biden but just people
that aren't there people that are kind
of vacant to the issues that the
underclass
will will connect on some dangerous
which is kind of what we're looking at i
think it's a lot of poor people out on
the street rioting i don't know for sure
not necessarily in new york it was a
several rich people
and rich daughter yup they're bored rich
kids
that's what i was saying yeah this is
affluenza they're rich people
so that's a saying to a hammer
everything looks like a nail to a racist
everything is predicated upon race wow
so when you have
people like uh you know what i'm not
gonna name people i could
because a lot of these people like were
straight up saying things
talking about their privilege and
getting away with things because of
their skin color and i'm like wow
i never perceived that i grew up in a
mixed area and when crimes were
committed and things happened
you could not assume it was based on
race because everybody was a different
race
everybody different skin color different
parents some people had an accent some
people didn't
so when something would happen you
couldn't see a pattern in that
but when you get people like robyn
d'angelo just telling you over and over
again
remember that time that cop let you go
it's because of your race
and then the the young girl goes oh
meanwhile her dad's writing a check to
the mayor and he's like
this has never happened i mean so this
kind of thinking is contagious
because robin d'angelo is a racist and
she's talking to people who are
in higher classes who have the class
advantage so this might be something
that they never
thought about before but now that she's
telling them they're like oh
maybe there's something to this because
i have noticed that i do have an
advantage and she wrote a book
so she has a phd man yeah all of a
sudden
her words have more meaning i guess
right no i'm being sarcastic but i think
that that's kind of a brainwashing thing
that someone with a phd or that wrote a
book
has more meaning in their words somebody
said what was the goal
you know what is the end goal of
critical race theory and it's to
leverage white guilt for money
oh brutal yeah yeah dude that seems to
be the thing i mean
you know giving these really high high
cost expensive seminars writing these
books
regurgitating these crackpot ideas so
people are paying money to go to school
to be told that they're a racist
yes that's insanity that's a racket man
i love it that's a dangerous racket too
did you see that do you see the video of
the
of the morbidly obese woman and she's
got the paypal thing
yeah that that is like people are saying
that's the perfect example of critical
race theory
in the video she's yelling at people
she's like you know i think that you
know
white people aren't human and you're all
demons so i'm like why are these people
sitting here taking that that was so
weird to me she was like
i'm not saying this to be mean but i
actually think you're all
demons that's not it just hurts like
what and they were just sitting there
placidly yeah
taking it freaking cows
history thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you